Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Und einunddreißig C drei so.
Buch, Netzpolitik, die einhundertsechsundzwanzigste Ausgabe, live vom einunddreißig C drei, wir sind nicht alleine. Hallo.
Also ich hätte echt nicht gedacht, dass ihr wegen, also dass ihr deshalb hier seid. Die hauen auch bestimmt irgendwie gleich ab, weil wissen die nicht, wo Saal eins.
Ja, Linus, ist noch ein bisschen äh unpässlich, aber das wird sich sicherlich gleich finden. Der Rest ist, glaube ich, ganz entspannt, oder? Wir haben nämlich heute ein, ein Allstar-Team äh versammelt und begrüßen. Äh, Thomas, Thomas Luninger, hallo.
Und genau, dein Applaus,
und es gibt noch ein Upgrade, nämlich Andrea, Andre Meister, hallo.
Andre musste ich gestern eine Stunde bequatschen, dass er kommt, weil er wollte eigentlich ein Tor gucken.
Bist du nicht auch wegen Talks hier?
Wer ist hier schon wegen der Talks? Ja, man sagt immer nur so, ja, hier, oh, tolles Programm und so, ich gucke mir bestimmt zehn Talks an und so, das macht man sich so ein bisschen wichtig und dann steht man an der,
So ist das Kongressleben. Ja, aber es gibt ja noch das Sendezentrum, da kann man auch äh gepflegt abhängen und wir blicken hier auf ein äh unübersichtliches Heer von äh Zuhörern. Das finden wir total super. Und ich habe so den Eindruck, ihr habt den Podcast schon mal gehört.
Ähm ja, wo wir dann schon mal dabei sind, dann würde ich sagen, fangen wir doch mal mit dem Kongress an. So ähm,
War irgendwas? Ist schon mal irgendwas passiert? Ist jetzt also es ist ja der zweite Tag. Ist ja schon ein bisschen was gelaufen.
Welchen Talk verpasst du denn jetzt gerade?
So viel weiß ich auch nicht dafür, äh darüber als was in der Ankündigung stand.
Die ist aber relativ ausführlich, ist glaube ich die längste Ankündigung, die wir haben.
Aber deswegen muss ich das jetzt hier auch nicht rezitieren, weil hier sind ja so viele Leute beim Kongress, die haben ja den Fahrplan alle komplett gelesen und wissen, worum's da geht.
Naja, aber wir haben ja auch noch äh A äh Hörer jenseits des.
Die nicht auf dem Kongress sind?
Ja, wir strömen ja hier direkt ins Netz, ja? Und du weißt ja, Podcasts werden auch in fünfhundert Jahren noch gehört. Insofern.
Ich habe den Tok ja noch nicht gesehen, deswegen kann ich leider nicht so viel darüber sagen. Auf jeden Fall das Invisible Comity sind ähm das ist so ein bisschen verschwommen, ich habe auch nicht so viel Ahnung von Frankreich,
aber es gab vor zwei, drei Jahren in der Anklage gegen neun linke Aktivisten und Aktivistinnen in Frankreich, die nennt sich die Tanak9, da ging's, glaube ich, um Atomproteste,
Einem von denen wurde auch noch vorgeworfen, die Anna anarchistische Streitschrift äh der kommende Aufstand äh geschrieben zu haben,
und die melden sich jetzt zurück, obwohl noch äh diverse Terrorverfahren laufen und haben ihre Kritik an Gesellschaft, Kapitalismus,
und der Moderne jetzt auch auf die Digitalwelt ja erweitert und vor allem die Kritik die kommen zurück mit einer Kritik, fuck Google. Mehr weiß ich auch nicht, das war das TL, DR des Talks, aber,
Linus hat mich ja zwangsverpflichtet, Podcast zu machen, deswegen werde ich irgendwann das Recording schauen müssen.
Ich auch.
Wenn ich mal dazu komme. Ja genau. An der Bar.
Das geht hier immerhin.
Wir haben ja nicht nur Bombenleger äh Talks geguckt. Wir haben ja auch das Zentrum für politische Schönheit geschaut. Hast du das auch mitgeschaut? Äh Thomas.
Äh von Remote auf meinem Telefon noch im Hotelzimmer, aber ja. Ähm als ich ich an der Bar, genau.
Gar nicht so schlecht als Netzpolitiker in diesen Tagen,
jetzt auch mit Sauna.
Äh nee, aber äh mir gefällt das irgendwie, dass das so äh Aktivismus und Kunst zusammen gewürfelt wird. Also ich glaube, das war ja auch ein bissel so die Absicht bei dem bei der Keynote von Alex Empire,
da ist das eher schiefgegangen, aber das mit dem Zentrum für politische Schönheit war äh schon sehr inspirierend. Genau. Äh sehr, sehr strukturiert.
Ja, also auch eine eine wärmste Empfehlung, das Zentrum für politische Schönheit. Haben wir noch weitere warme Empfehlungen der bisher stattgefundenen Talks.
Ich kann den Talk von Alex Haldermann empfehlen, der hat über E-Voting äh im Allgemeinen und E-Voting-Systeme Internet äh Wahlen in Estland berichtet,
und das ist aus verschiedenen Perspektiven ziemlich spannend. Wir hatten ja hier vor vielen Jahren die Debatte um Wahlcomputer, Wahlmaschinen in Deutschland, unter anderem mit großer Hilfe von Rob und dem CCC,
Wahlcomputer in Deutschland wieder verabschiedet, weil die eben keine äh gleichen, freien und geheimen Wahlen gleichzeitig garantieren können,
Estland macht das mit Internetabstimmung, so jeder an seinem Rechner zu Hause per App.
Klingt verrückt, die stehen total drauf, die haben das halt einmal auseinandergenommen und die haben auch jede Menge Kritik, dass das eben durchaus hackbar ist, im Gegensatz zu ja, wie die Befürworter,
immer beteuern und dass man das eben nicht als IT-Projekt eine Regierung mit so ein bisschen Security rangeflanscht sehen muss,
sondern eben als äh na ja das Wort kritische Infrastruktur klingt immer so bescheuert, das klingt immer gleich nach Cyber,
aber durchaus nach Fred Level, man hat's mit anderen Nationen zu tun und gerade Estland, wo angeblich Russland schon mal,
Banken für mehrere tagelange haben soll. Da fragt man sich das schon, ob die sich das mit den Abstimmungen im Internet soweit überrascht haben, haben wir noch eine kleine Überleitung,
der neue ein neuer EU Digital Vizekomissar, der Herr, der kommt aus eng, der kommt aus Estland und der steht da total drauf,
und der ist der Chef von Öttinger und der ist für Digitales zuständig, auch die haben da auch 'n Personalausweis mit Identifikation und Signaturenmöglichkeiten, denen wir alle nutzen, im Gegensatz zu Deutschland,
und der der findet das alles total toll und der hat bestimmt voll die Initiativen und Ideen das auch aufzusetzen,
Wir werden sehen, was da noch kommt, was welche Fights, die wir gedacht haben, die wir vor fünf Jahren gewonnen haben, wir dann nochmal auf EU eben eine neue.
Worüber, worüber, wie machen die das? Wie stimmen die da ab? Also was was benutzen die da konkret.
Laden sich eine Software runter,
auf ihren Windel, ne? Es gibt auch für Apfelcomputer und Linux und weiß ich nicht, es gibt bestimmt auch per App und dann kriegst du irgendwie,
irgendwas an, dann kriegst du ein PDF aus äh PDF zurück und das lädst du dann irgendwie wieder hoch und das wird dann mit deinen,
Personalausweis, Signatur, signiert und dann verschlüsselt und dann kommt das auf so ein Silver. Ich kann Ihnen einen Talk empfehlen, gibt's wie alle anderen ähm auf als Recording,
und er hat nebenbei auch noch über Wahlcomputer in Indien und auch die ersten äh Systeme,
in Holland und auch die Firma in USA, der hat so einen kleinen Rundumschlag gemacht,
Betonung auf von warmen Maschinen, weil Computern weg, auf Internet-Voting dann in Estland.
Dieses Thema, das wird uns auch nicht verlassen so schnell, ne?
Er hat, glaube ich, einen ziemlichen Krater hinterlassen.
Ja, bei uns, aber da draußen gibt's noch andere Leute, die politischen Entscheidungen treffen und die sind nicht immer alle auf dem Kongress.
Hören.
Sollen wir nur politische machen oder sollen wir auch über Starbucks äh biometrische Systeme sprechen.
Wir können hier über alles reden. Wir sind frei, äh Menschen.
Ein sehr unterhaltsamer Talk von Starbuck, der sich mal ein bisschen mit der mit der größeren,
Auflösung von Kameras heutzutage auseinandergesetzt hat und geprüft hat, hm, was für ein Objektiv man denn braucht, um aus der ersten Reihe bei einer Bundespressekonferenz,
Finger von ähm ein ein Foto von dem Finger von Ursula von der Leyen zu machen, um damit ein reproduzierbaren äh Fingerabdruck herstellen zu können und hat dann ähm im Laufe seines Talks,
Fingerabdruck von Ursula von der Leyen released.
Aber wie hat er denn verifizieren können, dass das jetzt auch wirklich das also dass es so identisch ist, dass es wirklich auf einen mit ihrem richtigen Finger trainiertes System auch anschlägt.
Gehst du hin? Nein, er hat er hat's einfach auch nochmal an sich selber ausprobiert und dann konnte er es ja quasi testen.
Er hat seine eigenen Fingerabdruck auch noch.
Man kann auch von sich selber Fotos machen, wenn man einen Freund.
So ein Selfie, ja sag das doch gleich. Man muss schon, man muss jetzt auch schon ein bisschen so in der Trennsprache bleiben. Okay, also so ein Fingerselfie.
Finger Selfie. Finger Selfie ist das neue äh Passwort eins, zwei, drei.
Hast du noch was gesehen oder bist du hier irgendwie.
Er ist aufgeregt, der hat noch seinen eigenen Talk.
Ja, nein, aber ich habe.
Aber dieser, dieser Hack, dieser Hack, der, der, der hat mich ja heute Morgen um meinen Schlaf gebracht, weil mich wieder irgend so eine Presse, so eine verzweifelte Pressequelle, ha, ich brauche unbedingt einen Ansprechpartner.
Nicht ans Telefon.
Könnt ihr schon um elf Uhr anrufen, das ist Kongress.
Also ich habe äh SWR Info für morgen auf halb acht äh runtergehangen,
die wollten zehn vor sieben. Freunde.
Oh Gott, äh na ja, da macht man was mit. So, aber ich habe dich unterbrochen.
Nee ähm die Deutschstunde war wieder toll, also Maras Vortrag. Ja. Ähm der hat sich ja wieder mal ähm was was äh flinguistisches angeschaut, also ich glaube, das war die digitale Agenda, die er analysiert hat.
Einiges zu holen.
Ich bewundere ihn auch immer wieder äh mit mit welcher stoischen Ruhe er da durchgeht. Also man wünscht sich ja immer so einen Deutschlehrer eigentlich, ja, der, der, der mit so viel,
äh Wissen und gleichzeitig aber auch mit so einer ganz schwarzen, zynischen Humor an an Dinge rangeht. Ich glaube, da hätten wir alle viel mehr Spaß in der Schule gehabt.
Ja, wir Basel Reich Ranitzki immer so schnell sagte. Wie sind Sie als Kritiker, muss ich mich mit so viel Dreck befassen? Ja.
Viele gute Leute sind dieses Jahr.
Aktionismus hilft ja merkt man ja regelmäßig um sich so ein bisschen durchzuwalken durch diese ganze Themenlandschaft.
Ansonsten, was äh mich eigentlich am meisten begeistert hat, war kein Talk, sondern ein Film, also Citizen vor, ähm den genau.
Laura Potcha. Wie spricht man das eigentlich richtig aus? Portos.
Das das war ich hab ihn zum ersten Mal hier gesehen und das war wirklich ja Zeitgeschichte, also wenn man sich den anschaut, das ist ja eine reale Dokumentation von etwas, dass das mal in Geschichtsbüchern stehen wird, hoffentlich,
und ähm dass man wirklich diese Momente miterleben kann, äh wie diese Information rausgekommen sind und vor allem, wie das menschlich alles abgelaufen ist,
ähm das ist schon wahnsinnig und vor allem ähm hier, der der Porsche ist auch nochmal zu danken, weil sie auch diejenige war, die Snowden am Anfang geglaubt hat, als er nur,
irgendeinen Citizen vor, irgendein Nick nehmen war, der Sie per E-Mail kontaktiert,
äh sie ist da diejenige gewesen, die einfach rational geblieben ist und die ähm einfach so weit mitgedacht hat, bis sie ihn bis ihr klar war, hey, okay, da ist wirklich was dran. Ich reise jetzt nach New York. Ich ich glaube den Typen einfach mal,
Hätt sie das nicht getan? Wer weiß, wie die Geschichte ausgegangen wäre?
Ja, kann man froh sein, dass sie nicht schon CCC Medienlisten abonniert hatte. Da müssen wir wahrscheinlich schon so ein bisschen, ah, was ist das denn jetzt schon wieder? Spam,
Ja, aber dieses ganze Filmmaterial, was sie verwendet hat, das hat sie quasi ab dem, ist das so, ab dem ersten Kontakt schon entstanden, also ist quasi direkt mit Kamera angereist und hat gleich.
So im Hongkonger Hotelzimmer ähm hi, mein Name ist also wirklich vom vom,
so ziemlich ersten Moment oder ersten Tag an und äh das ist schon bemerkenswert, vor allem eben auch, weil's äh versucht so ein bisschen das, was medial danach passiert ist, auch noch mit reinzunehmen. Also wie hat das die die Welt und die Diskussion verändert?
Ähm das ist jetzt nicht der Film, der die ganzen Details der Revolutions erklärt, aber er er schafft es irgendwie so dieses grundsätzliche Prinzip,
von den ganzen, was Noden uns gebracht hat, äh zu vermitteln. Und deswegen glaube ich auch, dass er super für Schulklassen wäre oder für irgendwie so politische Bildung, ähm weil ich glaube, wenn der Film es nicht schafft, dass Leute anfangen drüber nachzudenken, dann schafft's eh nichts mehr.
Was hast du denn für einen Eindruck von Snowden? Also hast du irgendeinen Eindruck von Snowden bekommen, den du so noch nicht hattest?
Ja, einen sehr menschlichen, also ähm,
äh in in der Hinsicht, was fast ein Helden äh weil er da ja schon äh auch sehr klar erklärt, wieso er das getan hat und was für ihn die Beweggründe waren,
und ähm solche Menschen kann man sich nur wünschen. Ich meine, das das hat schon irgendwie auch was äh mehrtyranmäßiges. Ähm es reflektiert auch so ein bisschen,
Aber für ihn ist es halt wirklich einfach eine Entscheidung. Äh ich ich will, dass die Welt besser wird und insofern mache ich das jetzt auch für mich, dass ich äh mein ganzes Leben und meinen Beruf und meine Familie riskiere, äh damit die Welt das wahr ist,
Das ist so irgendwie das das i-Tüpfelchen und äh ich denke auch, wer der Film irgendwie ein bisschen früher erschienen, dann werden diese ganzen Snoten,
auch vielleicht bewusster reflektiert worden, dann hätte man da vielleicht irgendwie mehr,
Sinn draus machen können, weil mir ist es zumindest oft zugegangen, du wirst einfach weggeschwappt von so viel Informationen, alle paar Wochen wieder eine neue große Revolution.
Es gibt ja 'nen relativ fundierte Kritik an dieser ganzen Fokussierung überhaupt auf eine Person, egal welche es ist und,
Wir haben ja bei Wiki Leaks gesehen, was es einer Sache schaden kann, wenn man sie halt zu sehr an eine äh Person bindet oder vor allem, wenn man die gesamte Glaubwürdigkeit und Seriösität des Unterfangens,
an den Ruf einer Person bindet, die diesen Ruf dann relativ nachhaltig ruinieren kann. Insofern,
also ich hab den Film noch nicht gesehen, weil ich mir gedacht hab, ach komm, der läuft ja beim Kongress. Sind aber leider dann nicht reingekommen.
Aber ich, also ich weiß, ich bin mal gespannt. Also ich habe den Film nicht gesehen, aber gerade dieses diese äh Heldenepos Geschichte weiß ich gar nicht, ob das unbedingt so sein muss. Also würde ich vielleicht gar nicht unbedingt.
Stimmen stimme dir zu, wenn's um Kampagnen und Themen geht. Man muss die, die Sache immer vom Menschen trennen und Menschen sind weitaus leichter fehlbar.
Aber wenn sie eben nicht scheitern, wenn sie schaffen irgendwie sich äh auf die Dinge zu konzentrieren, dann,
dann können sie auch ein wahnsinnig wichtiges Vehikel sein, um die Geschichte zu erzählen, weil du musst eine Geschichte halt einfach für uns Menschen immer mit äh anderen Menschen, mit Personen erklären.
Ja, ich bleibe dabei.
Möchtest lieber Themen statt Köpfe haben, ne? Das ist ja ein sehr erfolgreiches Konzept, wie wir wissen.
Aber einen Satz muss ich auch noch zum Film sagen. Ich habe den zwar gestern nicht gesehen, dafür aber auf der Premiere im November, deswegen ist es schon ein bisschen her,
Aber das war gar nicht die Intention von Laura irgendwie, den Snoden zu porträtieren, weil der Film ging auch gar nicht erst mit Snoten los im Hotelzimmer, sondern sie hat schon ein Jahr vorher gefilmt. Äh sie hatte,
Workshops gemacht, gefilmt, mehrere. Die hat sich mit Leuten vom CCC getroffen, sie hatte mit den Whistleblowern,
schon gefilmt und sie war schon dabei einen Film über über weltweite Überwachung durch Geheimdienste und Whistleblower zu machen,
und dann kam Snowden und hat sie kontaktiert und das hat natürlich den kompletten Film auch nochmal über den Haufen geworfen. Äh deswegen sind da so ein paar Szenen drin, die auch nicht so wirklich,
die für mich nicht so wirklich gepasst haben. Ich wusste, dass sie schon vorher gefilmt wurden und dass sie schon immer auf der richtigen Seite war und sowas machen wollte, aber mit diesem Weltexpost äh Whistle Blower, der da plötzlich,
Ein Jahr lang die Medien dominiert. Äh man merkt den Film an, dass sich da so ein bisschen was verändert hat. Aber ich habe auch mit ihr äh gesprochen, diese Personalisierung,
ist natürlich immer ein schwieriges Thema, das andere Problem als Filmemacherin oder Filmemacher ist halt.
Es gibt keine Bilder von weltweiter Überwachung. Wir sind ja in der Tagesschau, dann kommt dann wieder irgendwie das Rack mit irgendwelchen Glasfasern und fünfundvierzig Steckern,
wenn die Überwachung bebildert wird und da gab's halt das erste Mal 'ne Person,
auch weltweit das so ein bisschen zugeordnet werden konnte. Lora würde sich wünschen, Bilder davon zu haben,
gefahren hat dieses dort gefilmt und so. Sie hat schon versucht Bilder zu finden wo es nur geht aber dann im Endeffekt die Stimmung in den zwei drei intensiven Wochen dort eingefangen. Äh ich finde den Film auch,
sehr gut, ist schon ein bisschen her, dass ich den gesehen habe, aber für mich ist da so ein bisschen diese,
von eigentlich wollte die schon das schon vorher machen und dann kam dieses Noten und hat alles verändert. Das habe ich den Film.
Du denn da, dass du den gesehen hast?
In Berlin war im Kino international, Premiere im November und seitdem läuft er auch in Kinos, man kann den auch kein Geld bezahlen und in so große Häuser gehen und da wird der gezeigt.
Und die verkaufen Popcorn.
Jetzt auch mit Popcorn. Super. Ja, nee, ich hatte noch keine Zeit gefunden. Und ich dachte mir auch, läuft ja auf dem Kongress. Man kommt ja zu nix hier. Ja.
Ja, dann wollen wir uns nochmal den Themen des Jahres widmen,
müssen wir müssen mit einem kleinen Bruch anfangen, weil wenn Thomas auf einer Bühne ist, dann ist natürlich ein Thema nicht weit und das ist die Netznetralität, zu der er gleicht dann ja auch hier noch ein Referat halten wird.
Referat.
Stimmt, du bist ja gleich dran, ne?
Dreiviertel zehn. Ach okay,
Äh ja, also im Talk geht's eigentlich ähm ich hatte ihn gemeinsam mit ähm REO Zengo von bin zufrieden. Der wird so über die niederländische Situation sprechen. Die haben ja schon ganz lange ein irrsinnig gutes Netzzentralitätsgesetz,
und er wird so irgendwie aus der Praxis berichten was denn dann doch noch die Probleme damit sind,
und äh ich fokussiere mich natürlich auf das, was wir im letzten Jahr in Europa gemacht haben, also was ist alles äh,
bei Safety Internet passiert damals und ähm wie geht's dort weiter, vor allem, weil wir sind ja da noch nicht fertig, obwohl das Parlament äh für Netzzentralität gestimmt hat, müssen wir immer noch durch den Rat,
da schaut es gerade leider ziemlich beschissen aus, weil Deutschland jetzt im Dezember nochmal einen Vorschlag gemacht hat, der so auf ganzer Linie eigentlich das ist, was äh die Industrie sich wünscht,
und wirklich äh ich ich habe da auch schon eine Vergleichstabellen, äh wo ich mal alle Gesetze, die mir untergekommen sind, äh miteinander, die vergleichen gegenüberstelle,
Hat's wirklich geschafft, äh in jeder Kategorie so ziemlich das Schlechteste abzuliefern, was man bis jetzt gesehen hat.
Deutschland,
Deutschland.
Der ist wenigstens, auf die ist wenigstens Verlass.
Ja. Wir belegen auch einen stolzen letzten Platz hier in der Glasfaservernetzung. Super, läuft alles richtig.
Tim, die Netzneutralität wird doch jetzt abgeschafft, damit wir Glas kriegen. Das.
Super.
Das ist der Deal? Super. Sicher. Wir haben wir haben jetzt Regulierungsferien. Es äh die dürfen einfach machen, was sie wollen und dürfen sich auch gegenseitig aufkaufen, sodass wir nur noch vier große ISBs in Europa haben, aber dafür haben sie hoch und heilig versprochen, wenn sie die Netze aus,
so ein bisschen, glaube ich, das, was im Hintergrund äh.
So, wir pflanzen auch Bäume, wenn ihr alle aufhört zu atmen, ja?
So ein bisschen. Ja also so ähm wie war dieser Spruch nochmal?
Äh die Netznetralität aufzugeben, um besseres Netz zu bekommen, ist wie das Bild zu verkaufen, um sich einen besseren Bilderrahmen leisten zu,
Ähm und wir haben halt jetzt das Problem, dass dieser Vorschlag von Deutschland, Deutschland ist in der EU einfach ein sehr starkes Land,
und es gibt auch andere große Länder, die das leider ähnlich sehen. Das heißt, es wird ein schwieriger Kampf, aber es gibt so die gute Seite, das sind in dem Fall die Niederländer und die Polen,
die sich zusammengetan haben und einen irrsinnig guten Text auf den Tisch gelegt haben,
und ja, jetzt geht's halt einerseits drum, ob es vielleicht in Deutschland nicht doch nochmal äh genügend zivilen Ungehorsam gibt, dass sich die vor allem die Sozialdemokraten da nochmal umorientieren, weil Sigmar Gabriel ist eigentlich fürs Wirtschaftsministerium,
am Tisch, im Rad und ähm.
Prinzipientreuer Politiker kann ja nichts schief gehen.
Ja, du äh ich bin Österreicher, ich ich weiß eigentlich, wie das läuft mit großen Koalitionen, aber äh ja, wie gesagt, äh ich hoffe halt irgendwie, dass man erinnert, Deutsch noch was tun kann, ansonsten im Rat wird's halt wirklich ein schwieriger Fight.
Warum denn Polen und Holland?
Äh na ja, die Niederländer, das ist klar, die ähm hatten da mal eine Debatte, da ist die Bevölkerung sensibilisiert für dieses Thema. Die haben auch ein Gesetz, wo sie stolz drauf sind, was sie nicht verlieren wollen.
Seit zweitausendzehn oder seit wann haben die das?
Elf, zwölf, elf, zwölf.
Auch so im Sinn, ja.
Und äh die Polen, das ist eine gute Frage. Ähm also wann die Polen hüpfen und wann die Polen irgendwie gute Netz Sachen machen. Äh das kann keiner wirklich vorhersagen, aber wenn sie sich mal was in den Kopf gesetzt haben, dann dann sind sie eigentlich recht durchsetzungsfähig,
und äh sind vor allem eben halt auch die kleinen Länder, die äh erkannt haben, dass ihnen so eine Regulierung überhaupt nicht helfen würde, weil deren deren Ice sind die ersten, die aufgekauft werden und dann hast du halt nur noch den den Mutterkonzern, der dir die Politik,
also es wird in Europa spannend, in den USA natürlich auch, weil Obama Sicherheits auch für Netzertralität geäußert hat,
sehr stark sogar das hat zwei Seiten, weil einerseits gut, ja das heißt wir haben nochmal einen starken Fischbrecher für dieses Thema,
Ich würde das ähnlich einsortieren wie diese äh letzte Policy bezüglich äh Abschiebungen, die er gemacht hat, wo er auch äh äh sehr viele illegale Migranten in den USA legalisiert wurden nachträglich,
Ähm das ist so ähnliche Symbolpolitik. Ähm ich meine, bei dem bei den Legalisierungen der Aufenthaltsbewegungen war es sogar ein wirklicher realer Impakt. Bei Netzneutralität hat er sich nur politisch geäußert, ist ob blickte Regulierungsbehörde, das zu entscheiden. Also im Moment hat er noch gar nichts getan.
Vor allem hat er überhaupt gar keine Mehrheiten mehr. Also auch diese dieser Vorstoß in der Migrationspolitik war ja nicht wirklich Gesetz, sondern sozusagen das, was er so per Präsidentendekret durchgedrückt bekommt, ohne jemand fragen zu müssen,
und was da so ab Januar mit äh der Republikanermehrheit äh in beiden Kammern, also Kongress und.
Repräsentantenhaus.
Repräsentantenhaus, was da noch von übrig bleibt, da mache ich mir nicht so viele Illusionen.
Und das das sehen wir aber auch bei der Zentralität, weil Tech Cruise hat dann ja auch sofort gesagt, Netzertralität ist Obama Care für das Internet. Also dadurch,
wunderbar. Ähm es gibt da auch einen schönen Comic dazu, der das nochmal schön aufdröselt für,
Aber wir wir sind halt ein Backlash. Also alles, was Obama jetzt macht, wird von den Republikaner einfach ins Gegenteil verkehrt,
und falls mal wieder ein republikanischer Präsident kommt, dann müssen wir uns drauf einstellen, dass genau das Gegenteil von dem, was Obama mal wollte, dann auch wirklich gesetzte Politik ist und Parteilinien. Das befürchte ich so ein bisschen.
Wir haben Merkel-Care. Ja, sehr nachhaltig.
Zuletzt, worüber ich auch noch in Talk reden will und das vielleicht ein bissel ein streitbares Thema ist, so irgendwie Global Sauf und Wikipedia Zero? Ähm das ist nämlich auch ein Thema, was was äh sehr wichtig geworden ist im letzten Jahr,
Ähm ich glaube, wir haben eh schon mal einige Male über Wikipedia Zero gesprochen, aber der Grund, wieso ich das jetzt auf die Agendaheber ist, weil äh die Wikimedia Foundation sich aktiv in Chile,
eingesetzt hat dafür, dass das dortige Netzertralitätsgesetz aufgeweicht wird,
Ähm das heißt die Foundation geht in ein anderes Land, um dort Bürgerrechtsgesetzgebung aktiv aufzuhebeln, damit sie ihr eigenes Produkt, ihr Wikipedia Zero dort durchbringen können.
Wer ist denn das dann? Ist das immer Jimmy Wales oder sind da mittlerweile auch noch andere Leute unterwegs?
Da ist ein Team von Anwälten, die äh in in den Staaten sitzen, für die Foundation arbeiten und die als einzigen Job haben. Äh Wikipedia Zero voranzubringen. Ähm das sind teilweise auch Leute mit sehr,
komischen Einstellungen zum Thema Netznetralität. Ich war da mal in London auf der Wikimania und habe mit denen gesprochen,
mein Eindruck ist, dass da auch so ein kleiner Graben ist zwischen den Leuten in Wigip Media und der Wikipedia Community, die das durchaus sehr kritisch sehen,
Aber die sind halt alle abhängig von der Foundation, die hat die Markenrechte und die sitzt eigentlich am Geldhebel von den ganzen Lokalen Chapters,
und innerhalb der Foundation gibt's halt überhaupt keine Prozesse, äh wie man sowas abstimmen könnte. Das ist nicht demokratisch,
ähm die haben irgendwie angefangen, Policy zu machen mit den, mit den ähm Acta, Blackouts und und äh diesen Geschichten damals und haben aber überhaupt nicht die Strukturen politisch zu agieren.
Ähm ist ein größeres Thema. Ich will auf jeden Fall mal anschneiden und das das ist so grob, worüber wir im Talk reden werden.
Einundzwanzig fünfundvierzig ich hatte seit.
Gut, ich denke, wir müssen auch nochmal so ein bisschen über die äh Geheimdienst äh Problematik äh sprechen, die sich dieses Jahr besonders äh,
in Deutschland abgezeichnet hat. Du hast ja da viel Zeit drauf äh gelegt, Andre mit der Beobachtung des NSA Untersuchungsausschusses. Wie viel Sitzungen hast du jetzt beigewohnt und wie viel davon live bloggend? Alle,
alle mitgemacht.
Keine Ahnung, das waren so ungefähr neun, acht, neun, zehn, wo ich da war. Einmal war ich auf der Fusion. Einmal war ich.
Betriebsurlaub.
Ach so, das war dieses andere Wochenende. Ähm einmal hat mich wettervertreten und hat mich Anna vertreten. Ich bin ja auch nicht alleine in Netzpolitik oder irgendwie äh Geheimdienstblogger, aber ich habe immer noch eine Rückfrage an euch. Machen wir jetzt einen Rückblick oder einen Ausblick?
Als auch. Ja, deswegen habe ich das Thema wieder mit hier reingenommen. Ich bin jetzt nicht nur der Typ, der mit dem NS Auer rum äh Hut rumrennt, ich habe noch andere Hüte, aber.
Ja, der, den du hast, ist sehr schick, sehr schick. Ja.
Ja schön, dass ihr das auch sagt.
Jedenfalls, äh wenn man in wenn man auf das Jahr auf das letzte Jahr zurückblickt oder auf das nächste Jahr blickt oder wenn man eigentlich irgendwas mit Internet macht, dann muss ich da wieder den Sascha Lobo zitieren, wenn wir über Internetpolitik, Digitalpolitik, Netzpolitik reden,
im Raum ignorieren,
Problem ist unsere komplette digitale Welt wird voll überwacht. Und es passiert immer noch nichts. Jetzt sind wir hier mit dem Motto in und dann steht bei Spiegel Online, jetzt geht's endlich los. Wir rufen dazu auf.
Jetzt geht's los. Ja, vielleicht sollte man das mehr mal in so Fußballhymnen äh umformen, um ein bisschen Impact zu erzeugen.
Hat heute noch einen Tag ähm versucht anzugucken, den von James Benford, US-Journalist, der schon seit dreißig Jahren über die NSA schreibt, äh als sie noch Nosach Agency hieß, der hat schon mit Büchern wie the Puzzle Palace,
ja Enthüllungen über die NSA gebracht da ja waren die meisten von uns noch ja und außer Tim war hier noch niemand im Internet.
Ja, aber Tim, der Einzige im Internet, der da ganz alleine da drin.
Und ja da da frage ich mich dann schon, dann kommt der erzählt, ja ich hab's ja vor dreißig Jahren schon mal gesagt und dann ist er hier Kasperbauden und erzählt auch äh das mit dem Prinzen habe ich vor drei, vier Jahren schon gesagt und mir hat niemand zugehört,
Untersuchungsausschuss der übrigens nicht NSA Untersuchungsausschuss heißt, sondern Geheimdienstuntersuchungsausschuss.
Gerade mal umbenannt. Äh geht ja auch um den BND,
aber dann erzählt er ja, wir hatten das Church Comedy äh in den siebziger Jahren in den USA, nachdem das Citizens Commission Turn Investic DFBI in einem FBI-Büro eingebrochen ist, äh und jede Menge Papierdokumente rausgetragen hat,
und dann das erste Mal äh an die Presse gewandt hat, um zu enthüllen,
was in den siebziger Jahren alles gegen linke Aktivisten, gegen Frauenrechtler, gegen Black Activists, äh gegen vermeintliche Kommunisten,
für Mittel von den Gediensten und ja von den Geheimdiensten und eingesetzt wurden,
bis hin zu Briefe an Martin Luther King, mit nimmt den Nobelpreis nicht an, sondern ähm äh bringt dich vorher selber um und so. Das hat das FBI gemacht
Und da gab's einen Skandal und da gab es öffentliche Berichterstattungen und dann gab's einen Untersuchungsbericht und die haben dann äh das sogenannte äh Church Comedy von Sanita Frankchurge,
Abschlussbericht geschrieben und da drin steht,
Also wenn die das so dürfen, was die da machen, dann haben wir keinen Platz mehr, wo wir uns verstecken können. Dann ist das eine allmächtige äh Geheimdienstmaschinerie. Das war in den Siebzigern. Danach ist alles viel schlimmer geworden.
Und dann kam das Internet äh nach Tim auch zu allen anderen und dann haben wir den Echolon,
Da haben wir dann hat äh unter anderem James Benford, aber ein paar andere, das Echolot und Spionagenetzwerk Ende der Neunziger enthüllt,
wir haben gedacht, OK, die überwachen einmal alles in der kompletten digitalen Welt, dann gab's 'ne Untersuchungsausschuss vom Europaparlament und da stand drin, die überwachen einmal alles in der digitalen Welt. Und wenn wir nicht aufpassen, dann ist es echt zu spät,
paar Wochen später war äh und dann ist alles noch viel schlimmer geworden,
Also wir haben jetzt unseren Helden mit schicken Filmen, wir haben einen Untersuchungsausschuss und jede Menge Presse,
aber ich hoffe, ich hoffe, dass sich die Geschichte nicht nur als Farce und Tragödie wiederholt,
sondern dass wir tatsächlich auch mal, dass es nicht noch schlimmer wird, nachdem der Untersuchungsausschuss irgendwann mal in einem Abschlussbericht gemacht hat, sondern dass hier ein ein neuer Aufbruch beginnt und wir gemeinsam alle Wege äh entwickeln können, wie wir tatsächlich mal rauskommen. Denn,
Ganz ehrlich, äh nur mit dem äh Ausschuss wird das nicht passieren.
Was ist denn so deine These.
Was ist denn da so deine aktuelle These, warum es alles nicht verfängt?
Also bewegt sich keiner, weil die alle irgendwie weil wie jemand hinter ihnen steht und sagt dot move.
Es ist extrem schwierig. Ähm Geheimnisse sind Machtinstrumente und wenn man die Macht hat, dann will man die auch nutzen, weil das ist einfach und hilfreich und tatsächlich wenn man,
Mächtiger Politiker ist, braucht man Macht zum Durchsetzern, dann hat man eine Polizei mit Gewaltmonopol, dann hat man eine Armee für Außenpolitik, dann macht man Politik auf dem Parkett, aber dann hört man auch die anderen ab. Das machen alle so,
deswegen haben da auch die Amis gesagt mit ihrem Telefon, die soll sich mal nicht so haben, die weiß doch wie das Spiel läuft. Tut sie tatsächlich der BND macht ja nichts anderes,
dementsprechend wenn man einen bestimmten Teil des Staates ist dann ist das das normalste der Welt und dann möchte man da drauf auch nicht verzichten. Die Frage ist halt wie viel kritische,
Öffentlichkeit, wie viel ja Demokratie von unten, wie viele Leute gibt es, die sie sich mit den Themen auseinandersetzen,
das interessiert und die sich dadurch durch dieses Machtinstrument nicht einschüchtern lassen, weil das ist ja auch ein Problem durch die Enthüllungen,
Leute, sind wir auch beim Vorratsdatenspeicherungsurteil im Bundesverfassungsgericht. Leute, wenn sie überwacht werden, verhalten sich anders und nehmen an bestimmten politischen Demonstrationen nicht teil, haben Angst, bestimmte politische Meinungen in der Öffentlichkeit auszusagen.
Auszusprechen zu bestimmten Treffen zu gehen und bestimmte Initiativen zu unterstützen das ist die Schere im Kopf und das ist ein riesengroßes Problem,
Deswegen äh finde es gut, dass das alles enthüllt wird. Äh es ist nur, ich habe die Schere im Kopf selbst bei mir festgestellt. Äh gehst du zu der bestimmten Aktion oder nicht?
Wer vielleicht vor einem Jahr oder vor zehn Jahren hätte ich mich noch anders entschieden und das ist das ist das die große Gefahr dabei, deswegen,
findest du gut, dass so viele Leute zusammen äh kommen,
Ein Zusammenhalt äh bilden sich vergewissern, dass die auf der selben Seite stehen. Und da muss aber auch was draus folgen, denn wie gesagt, nur an irgendeine Oppositionspartei zu appellieren, die dann verspricht, das wirklich alles besser zu machen,
sowie der Obama hat wirklich äh Guantanamo zu schließen, das wird nicht reichen,
Geheimdienste abschaffen, Revolution. Ich komme ja gerade nicht zum Invisible Comity, die sind im Saal eins.
Oh Mist, jetzt waren wir so nah dran und jetzt das. Ja, aber ich meine, was.
Politik hundertsechsundzwanzig Stadtrevolution.
Okay, das heißt, die Politiker sind zu sehr gebunden durch eine eine Machtkonstellation, die sich durch Geheimdienste, aber nicht nur durch Geheimdienste äh ausdrückt.
Die Leute wählen CDU und SPD, weil sie Angst haben und eingetrichtet bekommen, dass morgen irgendwie der Muselmann Dresden islamisiert oder was auch immer,
Also das Problem ist gesellschaftlich äh medial, äh Debatten, weiß, von Framing, ich habe sozialwissenschaftlich studiert, sorry, ich kann nicht anders. Ich könnte jetzt auch den Frank machen und sagen, ach, mit ein bisschen Krypto wird das alles wieder in Ordnung kommen.
Güdi, Hati, Hacker gegen die Überwachung des Internets.
Fast wie Rüdi.
Hooligans gegen Geheimdienste. Das wäre auch nochmal.
Ja, das könnte vielleicht sogar auch.
Also ich glaube, wir entwickeln hier langsam schon so einen kleinen.
Gehen, ja, da geht was. Hm. Ja.
Das Thema wird uns auf alle Fälle leider nicht verlassen, aber immerhin ist es mal auf der Agenda, denn wir waren ja schon immer die Aluhüter, die da gesagt haben, dass mit der Überwachung ist ganz schwierig, aber selbst Leute, wie der Sascha Lobo, haben uns da nicht richtig zugehört,
Jetzt haben wir Recht und jetzt müssen wir aus dem Schmalmassel aber auch irgendwie wieder rauskommen.
Okay und was ist so deine deine Individualempfehlung? Na ja.
So Couch-Potato, Active oder was. Ich saß ja in Saal eins.
Wo warst du? Ich bin nicht reingekommen.
Ja war voll, sorry. Ich wollte jetzt eine Revolution, aber war voll.
Das heißt, in also eigentlich bei den Geheimdiensten auch international haben wir eigentlich keine wirklichen politischen Erfolge erreicht, oder?
Ich sehe keinen, sag mir jemand einen.
Die NSA stuft auch vorseitenspeicherungsniveau runter. Aber das ist doch auch irgendwie versackt.
Nee. Ist ja nicht durchgekommen.
Haben den Ausschuss und Obama hat auch mal irgendeinen Bericht schreiben lassen und den dann komplett ignoriert und was haben wir noch? Merkel wurde jetzt versprochen, dass ihr Telefon jetzt wirklich nicht mehr abgehört,
Die Bundesanwaltschaft hat dann auch gleich die äh die äh Ermittlungen wieder eingestellt.
Gibt's eigentlich eine Geheimdienstdebatte in Österreich?
Ja, wir haben den Erich Möschel, ähm.
Der hat auch noch einen Vortrag.
Ja. Der hat auch schon seit so zwanzig Jahren alles gewusst.
Das ist auf jeden Fall noch eine eine schwere Empfehlung. Erich Möchel, Tag drei.
In der Früh so was um elf.
Ja, da kann man auch seine Österreichkenntnisse äh.
Ist sogar auch noch ein bissel Geographie dabei, da gibt's schöne Landschaftsfotos, da sind nämlich so äh wie heißt das genannt? Genau, auf der NSA in Austria. Ähm genau und da ähm.
Will er denn in Englisch halten?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Keine Sorge.
Ähm nein und ähm er hat da äh glaube ich auch wirklich schön mit Drohnen Sachen gefilmt. Er ist auch mal äh das war auch sein einer seiner größeren Scoops im letzten Jahr,
Wir haben ja über hundert internationale Organisationen in Wien und unter anderem ja auch die UNO mit der internationalen Atombehörde. Da haben sie jetzt so rund um diese UNO-Gebäude lauter neue Hochhäuser gebaut.
Und ihm ist aufgefallen, da gibt's ein paar lustige Antennen, die da auf ein paar Häusern stehen. Und die gehören amerikanischen Firmen und die zeigen genau auf die UNO,
Also es es gibt eine Debatte, ähm aber das ist noch nicht auf einem Niveau, wo irgendwas passieren würde, vor allem weil der österreichische Staat sich bis jetzt da irrsinnig passiv,
Ich habe das ja schon mal erklärt, mit mit diesen komischen Gesetzen, die es eigentlich allen Ländern erlauben, auf österreichischen Boden Geheimdienstaktivitäten zu machen und das so pauschal unter Straf und der Straffreiheit stellen,
Ähm das heißt äh es ist eine eine irrsinnige Passivität in diesem Thema, vor allem als kleines Land, glaube ich, ist es schwierig, sich.
Geheimdienst Markt liberalisiert sozusagen, ja? Hm.
Genau. Ne so. Das bringt doch gewisse Standortvorteile. So, wir sind neutral, ne? Ähm.
Aber was haben wir mit den mit.
Wär's mal mit einer Überwachungssteuer? Pro abgehörten Telefonat.
Standortnachteil, Steuer.
Aber wirklich, das könnte funktionieren, ja. Bist du? Ja, wir besteuern das.
Ist immer ein Standortnachteil. Kannst du nicht machen. Nein, das macht die Wirtschaft nicht mit, die wandern ab.
Im Falle der Überwachung vielleicht ganz.
Aber ähm ich meine, Debatten hatten wir doch jetzt auch genug, oder? Und es gibt irgendwie wenige, die in dieser Debatte ernsthaft noch die Meinung vertreten, dass das alles äh notwendig und gut wäre mit den Geheimdiensten,
mein ähm selbst die wildesten halten höchstens noch so, entweder gegen so. Äh ja ist nicht so schlimm, wie dargestellt. Aber.
Nee, das ist Filter-Bubble. Ähm.
Ich glaube, ich ich habe jetzt auch nicht die Antwort. Die hat niemand, glaube ich. Also es ist schon dieses gewisse Gefühl der Ohnmacht, wenn du es politisch betrachtest.
Ich formuliere es einer, haben wir einen Mangel an Debatten. Also ich habe keinen Mangel an Debatten. Ich habe echt keinen Mangel an Debatten. Ich habe ein bisschen Mangel an Ergebnissen, klein bisschen.
Aber so ich brauche ein, also debattieren,
kann ich gerne machen, aber ich wünsch mir schon auch wünschen, dass dann ab und zu mal was dabei ähm rumkommt. Und ich bin ein bisschen verärgert, äh jedes Mal wieder irgendwie Netzneutralität, Geheimdienste, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Urheberrecht durchzukauen,
und da muss halt irgendwann auch mal ein bisschen was kommen. Freunde, also jetzt an euch gerichtet.
Handlungsempfehlungen? Jammer ernsthaft.
Ich also natürlich müssen wir ähm,
dieses also Debatte reicht vielleicht gar nicht. Ähm Bewusstsein ist ähm,
denke ich, wichtig,
Aber es geht mir weniger um das Bewusstsein im Sinne von ich weiß, dass da jetzt abgehört wird oder so, ja das äh haben ja jetzt inzwischen alle mitbekommen, ähm aber so ein ich glaube, was was tatsächlich, was wirklich fehlt,
und ich weiß nicht wieso ist ähm das Bewusstsein darüber, was diese Maßnahmen bedeuten für unsere Demokrat.
In Europa, wirst du schwer, jemanden finden, der die Snowden Sachen jetzt nicht so grob mal,
verfolgt hat, ja? Oder der weiß, so die hören alles ab. Ja, da dieses Bewusstsein, dieses, das ist ja ein Wissen, dieses Wissen ist da.
Aber das Bewusstsein darüber, was das für eine Gesellschaft bedeutet und was das für unsere Zukunft bedeuten wird. Dieses Bewusstsein scheint äh zu fehlen.
Brauchen wir keine Debatten mehr drüber zu führen. Da sind vielleicht so ähm so schöne Filme wie ähm wir lieben Überwachung. Ja, das sind halt,
wichtige Beiträge dazu, dieses Bewusstsein äh zusätzlich zu dem Wissen auch,
zu schärfen, aber der andererseits stehen wir natürlich dann auch, denn selbst wenn wir alle das Bewusstsein haben, stehen wir nicht in der in der Situation, dass ihr irgendwie eine Änderung ins Haus steht,
und wir sind wahrscheinlich auch nicht in der Lage, ähm eine Änderung herbeizuführen, denn dieser gesamte Geheimdienstsapparat wurde ja nicht irgendwie äh demokratisch beschlossen und äh mit irgendwie durch,
durchgeführt unter den Augen der Öffentlichkeit. Und wenn wir jetzt sagen, das wollen wir so nicht mehr. Ich meine, als wenn die sich jemals an irgendeine gesetzliche Limitation gehalten hätten,
und insofern ja, es ist einmal, wir brauchen einmal das Wissen, das Wissen haben wir jetzt,
Wir brauchen das äh Bewusstsein und wir brauchen da eine Änderung. Und im Moment scheint es schon an dem Bewusstsein, dem Notwendigen der Gesellschaft zu hapern und selbst wenn das da wäre, sehe ich kaum eine Option, äh wirklich Änderungen herbeizuführen.
Um das mal echt so. Also.
Wir sind ja hier auf dem Kongress und es gibt ja hier viele Leute inklusive ich sag das ja auch manchmal ein bisschen Technik kann uns tatsächlich ein bisschen weiter helfen um die,
fast kostenlose Massenüberwachung der kompletten Welt äh in eine teure äh individualisiertere Überwachung zu überführen,
Aber das ist äh ein Argument, greifen wir auch ein bisschen zu kurz, das ist Selbstschutz, das ist dann wieder nur für die Elite und das ist vor allem keine politische Lösung für ein politisches Problem.
Außerdem ist das im Internet und ich darf hier nicht offen zur Revolution und Gewalt auf,
aber ich zum Beispiel zum Beispiel mehr Leute verklagen der James Bamfort hat auch gesagt die sollen alle in Knast,
ähm äh Überwachungsleute, die dafür Leute, die politische Verantwortung dafür haben,
durchzuziehen. Millionen Menschen anlasslos ihre Grundrechte zu berauben, warum zeigen wir nicht mehr Leute an? Der CCC hat doch schon ein paar äh Sachen eingetütet, vor allem mit Konstanze, Kurz und Previcy International zusammen.
Ja, wir ressourcen das aber bald aus.
Es braucht mehr davon äh finde ich. Ähm ich will sowieso mehr Leute verklagen, das mache ich jetzt aber erstmal für IFG-Anfragen äh und noch nicht für den BND-Präsident,
Vielleicht für den Bundestagspräsident, da ist ja auch noch die andere Story,
aber wie wär's denn zum Beispiel, wir haben da gestern den Vortrag von Zentrum für politische Schönheit gesehen, da war ja genau dasselbe Problem, wir hatten Waffendeal, Panzerdeal mit hundertachtzig Panzern, die geliefert werden sollen, aber der ist legal und da können wir nichts machen,
Also versuchen wir die Waffenfirma anders ranzukriegen, indem wir fünfundzwanzigtausend Euro Kopfgeld ausloben für irgendeinen Hinweis für Steuerhinterziehung, falsch parken oder was auch immer, was diese Leute, diese Eigentümer, diese Firma in den Knast bringt,
Warum machen wir das nicht für den BND und für die politischen Verantwortlichen der Überwachungsmaschinerie da draußen?
Das sind alles das sind alles Falschparker. Das äh ändert natürlich alles, ja. Ist ja.
Damit kannst du auch in Deutschland echt sehr Feinde machen.
Die waren vielleicht auch schwarz.
Betreten den Rasen.
Jetzt ist es aber wirklich das Maß.
Und die trainieren Müll nicht. Schwein. Andre hat's ja gerade schon angesprochen. Ähm,
Wir müssen uns natürlich auch so über Techniken des Selbstschutzes Gedanken machen und im letzten Jahr äh hat ja so die Kryptokalypse stattgefunden, mehrfach,
und ich hab's jetzt mal so die IT achso das habe ich jetzt nur geschrieben, das kann man gar nicht aussprechen, doch Sekokalypse,
War nämlich letztes Jahr. Wir hatten und so weiter, teilweise ähm,
Also die, die durchschnittliche Dauer äh zwischen entstehen der Sicherheitslücke und ähm,
Entdecken der Sicherheitslücke wurde durch den ein bisschen in die Höhe gerissen. Das waren fünfundzwanzig Jahre,
zwischen dem Commit und der Entdeckung des Problemes,
aber immerhin haben wir in der IT-Security im vergangenen Jahr doch ein bisschen aufräumen können. Ich meine, natürlich war das äh schockierend diese ähm diese Entdeckungen,
aber das Schöne ist doch, ich meine, sie sind jetzt weg,
Zumindest die wenigen die jetzt im im letzten Jahr gefixt wurden und ich hoffe, dass es ähm dass es so weitergehen wird und dass wir da ein bisschen ähm die Infrastruktur,
weiter härten können und vielleicht so das Vertrauen in unsere Systemen äh ein bisschen erhöhen können.
Ja, ich finde vor allem, es hat einen einen anderen interessanten Trend ausgelöst, nämlich dass äh auch, sagen wir mal so, die Firmen, die bisher immer so, ja, ach, hat die PS und so, wozu braucht man denn das? Läuft doch auch so,
dass es.
Also ich würde noch nicht sagen, das ist weg, aber das das ändert sich schon äh spürbar, ja, also nicht nur jetzt so, dass Google mal äh vielleicht auch seinen internen Traffic mal verschlüsselt et cetera. Das sind so die ersten Schritte, die jetzt ganz konkret auf den,
Snowden-Enthüllung äh basierten, aber eben auch so et cetera. Also bisher hat sich eigentlich keiner so richtig darum Gedanken gemacht, also
stehen oder steht das S auch für irgendetwas? Also so diese Härtung, diese automatischen Testsysteme, so SSL-Test et cetera, die jetzt auch solche Übersichten machen mit na ja, wer ist denn hier noch? Äh hätte hier noch irgendwie rote Lampen an
äh äh da ändert sich echt eine ganze Menge.
Und das äh fischt schon mal hin und ich meine, du hast es ja gerade gesagt, Andre, das ist ja quasi auch Frank Riegers These, die ja schon bei zehn Jahre Netzpolitik org, äh auch im Prinzip gebracht hat, so dieses,
die Kosten für Überwachung erhöhen, dadurch dass man einfach mal mindestens schon mal das umsetzt, was ohnehin schon möglich wäre. Also ist ja so, es wird einfach sehr viel gar nicht getan, was heutzutage,
mehr oder weniger kosten neutral äh durchgeführt werden könnte. Das kann schon eben dem äh Überwachungsmoment einen anderen PriceTack äh geben. Ich sage auch nicht, das löst alle Probleme, aber das,
Ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein interessanter Anfang, weil auf einmal müssen sich auch viele, die bisher,
auf zwanzig Jahre alten Security äh löchern oder eben einfach der äh Nicht-Verschlüsselung ähm ausgeruht haben, gesagt haben, na ja, wieso, hier kommt doch alles so. Äh die sehen halt jetzt mehr,
Stop-Schilder. Das habe ich so sehr elegant eingeflochten. Ähm.
Und mussten natürlich dann entsprechend aufrüsten, was sie auch tun werden oder auch schon längst äh getan haben teilweise, aber ich denke schon, dass das wäre jetzt auch, sagen wir mal eine Handlungsempfehlung,
Wir haben hier eine ganze Menge Admins. Wir haben hier eine ganze Menge Leute auf dem Kongress, die,
nicht unentscheidend sind bei der Festlegung, ja wie ist denn unsere Infrastruktur, ja, warum ist denn unsere Webseite überhaupt noch über HDTP erreichbar, warum,
sind denn diese Zertifikate irgendwie alt, kaputt, äh warum ist der Webserver nicht richtig konfiguriert?
Meinen auch, ja.
Grad sein, das ist ein bisschen dünnes Eis so mit.
Ja komm jetzt habe ich vor sechs eingeführt.
Wie.
Immerhin.
Clemens lächelt dahinten so.
Lächeln, der soll mal lieber mitmachen.
Aber ich ich glaube, du hast einen wichtigen Punkt, also ähm das schließt auch ein bissel an, was was Linus gerade mit dem Bewusstsein gesagt hat. Also wir sehen schon eine Veränderung,
vor allem so in in speziellen Berufsgruppen, da wo es also auch gesellschaftlich außer Zweifel steht, dass,
erhöhtes Interesse gibt, was zu schützen. Also jetzt äh alles, was so irgendwie im Berufsgeheimnis hat, sei das jetzt ein Anwalt, ein Steuerberater oder auch irgendwas, was Beratungsleistungen angeht,
oder auch nur personenbezogene Daten von einer Firma zur anderen schicken. Äh da wird heute nicht mehr einfach nur Google Dogs verwendet, wie das vielleicht früher der Fall war. Ähm.
Ja, da tun sich neue Geschäftsfelder für T-Systems auf, aber ansonsten ändert sich da doch auch nicht viel. Also.
Na, ist halt immer die Frage, wie nachhaltig dieser Trend ist. Ich glaube, da ist dann auch die Technik gefragt, irgendwie Alternativen zu liefern, weil weil das Bewusstsein ist im Zweifelsfall sogar schon da, nur da musste halt auch irgendeine Option geben,
das zu kanalisieren und in irgendeiner Form meistens halt leider auch über Konsum, über irgendwas leicht anwendbares,
ähm so zu verwenden, dass du eine Besserung herbeiführst, dass einfach Überwachung teurer wird,
Ich glaube schon, wenn wir uns mal auf die speziellen Berufsgruppen konzentrieren, kann das schon so ein schrittweiser kultureller Shift werden,
weil du gerade Admins angesprochen hast, ein Projekt, was ich dafür immer ganz wichtig finde ist better Krypto Punkt org. Auf bei der Crypto Punkt ORG findet man,
sehr leicht, einfach nur all diese Manuals, die äh Admins verwenden können, um eben zum Beispiel,
ähm und alles, was sonst noch gut ist für SSL auf ihrem Server einzurichten oder äh einen Jabberserver richtig zu konfigurieren. Ähm und das,
versucht irgendwie jetzt nicht, für die Masse tauglich zu sein, aber für alle Leute, die irgendwie ein bisschen Administration machen und auf diese Dinge Wert legen, die denen wird dort eigentlich recht gut geholfen.
Und ich glaube halt wirklich, es ist so in gewisser Weise auch vergleichbar mit der Ökologiebewegung, weißt du? Wir haben wir haben jetzt schon ein paar Supers gehabt,
den Leuten wird langsam bewusst, dass so wie sie mit ihren Daten umgehen, das das hat auch was von Schutz der eigenen Umgebung und der eigenen Lebensweise,
es fehlt halt wirklich noch an den Alternativen. Ich rede jetzt nicht von der politischen Ebene, ich glaub da sind wir wirklich noch weit weg, dass wir die Geheimdienste abschaffen,
wenigstens auf einer privatwirtschaftlichen, individuellen Ebene.
Diese Ökologiebewegung. Das ist immer ein schöner Vergleich. Und die Gaus, ja, also ähm Fukushima,
da war jetzt irgendwie ähm ein paar Jahre war Atomenergie halt out. So, das Ding ist aber immer noch an. Und die Japaner ähm kehren da jetzt irgendwie regelmäßig irgendwie jedes kleine Stückchen Fläche, was sich in was sich im Umkreis von diesem,
Atomkraftwerk befindet, irgendwie mit und halten dann nochmal einen Geigerzähler dran und räumen das wieder auf und leben irgendwie weiter. Die haben sich damit arrangiert. Und ähm dieser Ausstieg aus der Atomenergie,
äh
ist für dieses Land keine äh nennenswerte Option mehr. Es war ein tragischer Unfall. Schade, aber jetzt müssen wir nach vorne blicken und da hat sich kein Umdenken eingestellt. Das hat sich nie eingestellt. Gerade also ich meine, wie viel Atomkraftwerke sind,
viele äh Atomraketentests hat die Menschheit schon äh die Erde schon hinter sich, Klammer auf, es sind über zweitausend,
Ähm also ich sehe da nicht, dass da wirklich ein ein Umdenken stattfindet und ähm.
Diese diese äh kleinen und mittelständischen Unternehmen und äh Anwälte, die da jetzt gerade unters äh unters Rad kommen,
in den letzten Jahren. Ja, wunderbar, da wird's jetzt dann irgendwann wird man denen was Schönes verkaufen können, ähm dann können sie, können sie auch ein bisschen IT-Sicherheit haben und müssen nicht mehr über Web DE ihre Kram schicken.
Aber so der der wirkliche, der wirkliche Wechsel, der die wirklich der Paradigmenwechsel, der eigentlich jetzt äh seit einem Jahrzehnt überfällig ist,
den herbeizuführen das sehe ich nicht so wirklich. Jetzt hab ich ja beruflich ein bisschen mit IT-Sicherheit zu,
und äh sehe ja, wie das auch in so Unternehmen in Unternehmen so gehandhabt wird, ne.
Als ich vor ein paar Jahren in in dieses Feld gegangen bin, habe ich gedacht, ach geil, IT-Security, ne? Gehst du rein, bist irgendwie der der Typ im schwarzen Anzug,
Hacks, die Sachen, danach gucken alle und dann wird werden die Löcher gefixt und du hast hast dazu beigetragen, dass die,
dass die Infrastruktur gehärtet wurde und alles ist cool, ja?
Stellt sich raus so die IT-Sicherheit ist in so einem großen Unternehmen, sind das ungefähr so die größten Spielverderber, die echt keiner mag, ja? Weil,
Geschäftsmodelle werden irgendwie entwickelt, man will dann so seinen Dienst ausrollen und dann kommen auf einmal die Pupen von der IT Security mit so einer Liste, wo überall ein Häkchen dran muss und sagen, bevor da kein Häkchen ist, ähm,
geht dieses Ding nicht live und dann verzögern sich irgendwie Projektplänen und so. Keiner hat Bock auf die IT-Sicherheit in seinem eigenen Unternehmen. Ähm das sind einfach nur so die, die Spielverderber. Und aus diesem äh also wie sind wir da hingekommen,
weil IT-Sicherheit äh heute,
in nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern eigentlich weltweit als so ein ähm Thema gehandhabt wird. Ja, also man sagt immer so, okay, wenn ich diese zweihundert Häkchen in meinem Sicherheitskonzept habe.
Kann man mir zumindest keine ähm keine Fahrlässigkeit mehr unterstellen. Und dann ist mir eigentlich auch egal, was passiert,
Ja, dann bin ich zumindest nicht verantwortlich. Ganz im Gegenteil, äh wenn ich jetzt irgendwie ein ähm Minimalstandard nicht umgesetzt habe, auf irgendeiner Kiste, dann bin ich's vielleicht wirklich schuld gewesen. Aber wenn ich alles getan habe, was man als mir möglich bezeichnen kann, dann bin ich irgendwie aus dem Schneider,
und da finde ich jetzt ähm,
aus dieser ökonomischen Überlegung heraus, äh für das Unternehmen selber, was ist IT-Sicherheit? Ähm da gab's immer so dieses okay, wir müssen,
so viel machen, um unseren eigenen also unseren persönlichen Arsch in Sicherheit zu bringen, dass wir am Ende nicht fahrlässig waren,
Und dann gibt's gegenüber so eine ominöse Summe, was der potenzielle Schaden wäre, der entstehen könnte, äh dem Unternehmen, für den wir dann halt ähm verantwortlich wären oder nicht,
Und daher kommt jetzt Sony ins Spiel.
Bei bei äh Sony äh Entertainment wurde jetzt echt einmal alles aufgemacht, was dieses Unternehmen hat,
jeder Scheißvertrag, jede scheiß E-Mail, jeder Film, alles ja, also es geht irgendwie los über die äh Social Security Numbers von den ganzen Angestellten, über die Verträge der einzelnen Künstler,
über die persönlichen oder die beruflichen E-Mails des Vorstandes so einmal alles.
George Clooney ist Hochzeit. War auch das? Ja.
War auch da drin. Ja, sechsundzwanzig Terabyte, ich bin noch nicht ganz durch,
dieses dieses Unternehmen wurde also so das das ist wirklich der Gau, ne? Also es gibt nichts, was die noch haben. Die können auch gar nicht mehr anfangen, da irgendwas zu fixen, weil ja alles kaputt ist,
Also die können eigentlich nur so Strom rausziehen und irgendwie neue Computer kaufen und versuchen das diesmal richtig zu machen,
was ich damit für diese IT Security Branche so interessant finde ist, dass es jetzt wirklich mal,
ein ein Price-Tack geben wird an,
einmal alles geohnt und wir fangen von null wieder an. Und es ist aus also damit die Lehre die Richtige ist, wäre jetzt zu hoffen,
da vorne komplett eingeht, dass es dir nie wieder geben wird, die alle arbeitslos werden nach Hause gehen, nirgendwo anders mehr einen Job bekommen, weil man sagt, ich bin zu verrückt. Ich habe doch hier schon deine E-Mails gelesen, du kannst doch nicht ernsthaft jetzt hier und schau dir mal deine,
Aber äh George Clooney wird noch einen Job finden.
Ja, aber er kann nie wieder heiraten, also.
Also der kann bei uns irgendwie als Praktikant, da kriegt er nochmal irgendwie eine Chance. Aber ähm,
bin jetzt sehr gespannt, wie sich das äh wie welche Lehre jetzt so die gesamten äh,
Industriezweige. Aus diesem Phänomen ziehen werden. Und auch da habe ich jetzt so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, dass sich so ein äh Fukushima-Effekt einstellen wird, dass man sagt, okay, oh, das,
Das hat die ja echt in dem Jahr fast fünfzig Prozent ihres Gewinns gekostet,
Aber im nächsten Jahr war ja alles wieder gut. Und das könnte eigentlich behaupten, also dies, was auch immer man am Ende für einen ähm Preisschild an diesem Sony-Hack machen wird,
wird irgendwann äh in zwei Jahren in Form eines äh Prozentsatzes einfließen, wie man sein IT-Security-Budget berechnet,
und das wird nochmal spannend. Ich wünsche mir natürlich, dass diese ganze IT-Security-Branche, also die IT-Secret-Branche ist ja eigentlich vorwärtsgerichtet, ja? Aber die IT-Security und den Unternehmen ist es eigentlich nicht. Das ist halt.
Gerichtet, was meinst du damit?
Sicherheitslücken werden gefunden, werden geschlossen, werden neuer gefunden, werden geschlossen, werden neu gefunden, werden geschlossen. Sicherheitsniveaus werden ständig erhöht.
Schau dir.
In der idealen Welt.
Nein, das wäre jetzt eine harsche Kritik an unserem Security äh Track in bei diesem Kongress, dass wir bei,
über dreißig äh Vortragenden, die äh in der Regel von Sicherheitslücken berichten, äh die in der Regel dann auch äh im Nachlauf oder schon vor der Präsentation äh ausgeräumt wurden. Also diese Evolution findet ja statt.
Aber sie findet halt ähm viel zu langsam statt,
Ich würde mir natürlich äh für die Zukunft wünschen, dass man so von dieser verwaltenden, bürokratischen IT Security Compliance irgendwie, naja, zu so einer.
Strukturellen Sicherheitsarchitektur kommt, sowie Microsoft das auch mit Windows gemacht hat.
Ich war gerade bei Rudi.
Naja, aber ohne Witz, ich meine, Microsoft hat ja im Prinzip genau dasselbe Desaster, also mit XP und so weiter, da war das ja alles so richtig, wissen wir ja, alle war furchtbar. Und äh,
aber sie haben auf jeden Fall ihre komplette Entwicklung und Depleyment Strategie umgebaut,
unter Berücksichtigung von Security-Aspekten,
und das ist etwas, was man bisher so in der Form bei Softwareunternehmen, im Idealfall sehen kann, aber eben noch nicht bei anderen Unternehmen, weil da,
Sony ist halt kein, also ich meine, wir reden ja auch nicht von Soni der Technologiekonzern, sondern wir reden von Sony, wie heißt das offiziell, diese Brunch Pictures, genau. Ähm ja, was ja nochmal ein,
ganz andere Welt ist, so. Für die halt E-Mails so einfach so stattfinden und keiner macht sich ausreichend Gedanken da drum. Der deutsche Mittelstand sollte allerdings auch mehr über sowas nachdenken.
Deutsche Mittelständler, lass uns das lieber.
KMU ist angefangen.
Nein, das war Thomas. Ich habe da genau drauf geachtet.
So ein Berufspro.
Also worauf ich denke halt so, dass dass es so ein Teil, den ich halt äh als Ausblick sehe für zweitausendfünfzehn, IT-Sicherheit wird der Gau wird jetzt so ein ein Preisschild haben und da werden sich ein paar Sachen ähm ändern. Ich fürchte zum Negativen,
Also ich fürchte, dass ähm,
dass man jetzt halt, man hat halt an dem Gau jetzt einen Preisschild, das war vorher nicht wirklich so, ja, da war der Gow war vorher definiert als du verlierst ein paar Kundendaten oder äh deine Webseite ist nicht erreichbar oder so, ne?
Aber ähm Sony setzt da jetzt echt äh mal wieder Maßstäbe.
Ja, was mich ja vielmehr interessieren würde, wer war's denn jetzt eigentlich?
Das weiß ich nicht. Was? Nee, weiß ich nicht. Wer war, weißt du das? Gibt's seltenes.
Ich meine, es gibt äh ein paar interessante Blog-Artikel von ähm ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie der heißt, der Typ, der da auch so bei der,
Werke, der hat da drüber gepostet. Der meinte, dass wir halt seiner Meinung nach ein Insidejob, also auf jeden Fall wird generell angezweifelt, dass halt äh Nordkebria die Power hat. Äh Brust Schneider hat äh drüber geblockt, er hat's ein bisschen,
Differenzierter äh betrachtet und meint auch, der sieht jetzt die Motivation für so Insider,
nicht in dem Maße, wie auch immer. Es gibt da erhebliche Zweifel da dran, wer es war, ist letztlich für die Debatte so überhaupt nicht relevant, wer es war, ja, also was,
da auch die Motivation war, weil am Ende zählt ja nur das Ergebnis. Aber ich freue mich halt trotzdem, ob irgendwie Nordkorea eigentlich,
spielt.
Auch für die Zukunft, weil das wird ja jetzt wieder als Cyber-Angriff von Nation States äh gewertet,
und das ist auch eine Debatte, die in den, der kommenden Zeit leider nicht abnehmen wird, ich mein wir sehen extrem starke National wie die NSA, die auch aktiv Angriffe fahren im Netz,
um mal ganz abgesehen davon, dass die versuchen das komplette Netz zu önen, aber auch wirklich starke, es gibt kein System, was vor äh ihnen sicher ist. Aber wir sehen einen Haufen Bullshit, Cyber, Cyber Rhetorik da draußen, von kritischer Infrastruktur und,
jeder Zwölfjährige im Kinderzimmer wird unsere Stromversorgung lahmlegen können. Das ist auch eine Debatte, die nicht ab sondern zunehmen wird,
Deutschland IT-Sicherheitsgesetz in Europa, mit der Nistrichtlinie und den begleitenden äh der Bedarfsträger und Institutionen,
Wird, glaube ich, äh hat auf zehn Netzpolitik äh einen Cyber-Cyber-Vortrag gehalten. Äh ich glaube, das war ganz unterhaltsam. Ich glaube, das wird sie auf der Republika nochmal äh zu einem vollständigen Vortrag ausbauen wollen,
Wenn sie's nicht wollte, dann muss ich's jetzt machen. Ich hab's angekündigt.
Hm. Ja. Und sonst noch? Weiß nicht. Wo sind denn die anderen Klassiker?
Urheberrecht. Spannend. Hier, merkst du, wie die Begeisterung um sich greift? So, oh ja, jetzt haben wir richtig Urheberrecht.
Glaubt da hier jemand dran?
Die Kommission wird irgendwas machen. Damit ist zu rechnen, aber ob das in die richtige Richtung geht, wissen wir noch nicht,
Sie haben auf jeden Fall mal zigtausende Kommentare bekommen in ihrer Konsultation. Leute haben ihnen wirklich gesagt, was sie stört am Status quo,
Die Kommission hatte sogar so ein richtig schönes Dokument gepackt, wo man drinnen steht, was gerade alles Scheiße ist am Urheberrecht. Und was man nicht alles tun müsste.
Welche Leute haben ihm das gesagt.
Ähm das war eine offene Konsultation von ähm hauptsächlich Zivilgesellschaft, die sich da beteiligt hat, aber natürlich auch Industrie,
und ähm das haben wir jetzt auf jeden Fall in einem schönen Dokument, was was so das Problem ist. Die Frage ist, welche Lösung sie finden dafür.
Was kann schon schiefgehen?
Ja, ich meine, es gibt wenigstens gute Leute, äh Julia Reeder, die auch hier einen Vortrag hält äh zum Urheberrecht. Die wird sich jetzt für die Grünen um das Thema kümmern,
Ja, die ist ja in der Grünen Fraktion.
Ach so, in du bist ja Europaparlamentarier.
Es gibt es gibt ähm eine äh Piratin, die es ja geschafft hat ins Europaparlament und die ist bei den Grünen. Aber man muss auch sagen, bis jetzt macht die sich sehr gut. Ähm die hat sogar eine sogar eine würdige Nachfolgerin für Media Underdog da.
Soweit man das jetzt schon sagen kann.
Drei, dreizehn Uhr fünfundvierzig Saal zwei.
Hier steht vierzehn Uhr.
Ja, ist auch richtig. Ich habe falsch geguckt.
Ja.
Und was ist noch ein spannendes Thema Freihandelsabkommen? TTIP. Das ist das, was wir jedes Mal sagen, äh oh müssten wir eigentlich mal bei Logbuch Netzpolitik besprechen und das gesamte Jahr nicht hinbekommen haben.
Zwei Experten auf dem Kongress, die beide einen Vortrag dazu halten wollten und einer wurde genommen.
Das ist richtig, der von Katharina Nokuon. Genau. Äh auf wann hatten wir den denn? War der schon oder kommt der noch.
Das ist Tag drei, später am Abend oder so, ist das so ein Stunden-Slot.
Ja äh Tag drei, sechzehn Uhr in Saal eins.
Und das ist vor allem CETA, dass äh europäisch kanadische Freihandelsabkommen und ein bisschen äh TTIP äh was transatlantisch USA, äh Europa ist.
Der der oder die spricht.
Warte mal, Entschuldigung.
Katharina Nokuna.
Mit C. Ja. Deine Rechte sind in diesem Freihandelsabkommen nicht.
Genau. Zitter und ich würde annehmen, dass Teaser, das Trade and Service Agreement und eventuell auch TPP, das Transpacific, Partnership Agreement, äh werden auch Themen werden.
Internationale Handelsabkommen mit vier oder fünf, drei, vier, fünf Buchstaben ab.
Das totale ETLA Festival sozusagen, ja?
Niemand interessieren, die aber immense Auswirkungen haben, so wenn die deutschen Politiker sagen, hat uns die EU vorgeschrieben, können jetzt die EU-Politiker sagen, hat uns das Handelsabkommen vorgeschrieben.
Verantwortungsdiffusion.
Auch urheberisch mit drin, Datenschutz, alle unsere Themen könnten da mal eben so durch die Hintertür ausgehebelt werden.
Haben wir denn irgendwas schönes noch anzukündigen?
Ja
Cam nächstes Jahr. Ey! Ja, doch, doch, doch, da ist sie.
Ja, da kann man auf jeden Fall drauf hinweisen. Wer will?
Das nächste Jahr wird ein Licht.
Hinweisen, wer war denn,
wir waren ja alle, du warst ja auch schon häufiger, ne, dabei, genau. Ja, ich kann das machen, also Kämpf wird's geben, das äh,
Findet ja, wie manche immer wieder erschrecken, äh manche dann erschreckt feststellen, wenn sie sagen, ah, ich gehe nächstes Jahr doch nur alle vier Jahre statt und jetzt ist halt mal wieder soweit,
und äh ist eine neue Location gefunden worden im Norden Berlins und die ist sehr schick. Die ist auch viel größer als äh die Alter, das war auch äh bitter nötig. Wer auf dem letzten Camp war, hat ja gesehen, da war also Zelt an Zelt doch schon sehr dicht geflochten.
Ich habe äh wenig Illusionen, dass es sehr viel äh luftiger wird, weil der Andrang ist sicherlich nicht gering.
Aber ja, ich bin da sehr optimistisch, was den neuen Ort betrifft und es auf jeden Fall auch schön, dass wir einen gefunden haben.
Ist er öffentlich der neue Ort oder noch geheim?
Bekannt gegeben, das ist äh in in Mildenberg äh auf dem Gelände des Ziegeleimuseums und da findet das alles statt,
So eine alte Industrieanlage, da wurden halt Mercedes gebrannt, so für Berlin. Und ja, das äh sehr geeignet und nette Leute und schöne Umgebung und,
mit Hafen und Seen, Vögelein, die zwitschern und all das.
Man sollte sich ja sowieso auch viel mehr an den an der Natur erfreuen.
IT-Security so.
Sagen wir hier mitten im Betonkasten,
Ja, na ja, ich denke, es ist irgendwie alles äh gesagt, aber wir können ja vielleicht noch ein paar äh Danksagungen und sonstige Aufforderungen noch äh hinterherwerfen. Wie ist unsere Art ist, du hattest auch noch was, ne? Äh du wolltest äh du wolltest.
Kleines Casting ähm,
Ich habe ja eh schon mal darüber gesprochen, dass ich gerade in Österreich einiges tut, so mit Büro und generell netzpolitischer NGOs aufbauen und weiterbauen,
und etwas, was da noch fehlt, sind äh Leute. Äh wenn's so irgendwie ähm Interessierte, Netzpolitisch interessierte Leute gibt, äh egal ob jetzt im aktivistischen Feld oder,
technisch oder einfach nur so,
dann sollen die mal bitte alle irgendwie 'ne E-Mail an info at aka vorrat AT schicken und ich würd die nämlich gern alle kennenlernen und so ein bisschen den,
den Pool an Leuten, die potenziell bereit wären, was zu tun oder auch nur mitzudenken, um Feedback zu geben und wirklich was machen wollen, äh diesen Pool will ich vergrößern, weil der ist in Österreich einfach noch,
viel zu klein.
Info at aka Vorrat Punkt AT.
Ich habe auch noch eine kurze Intervention. Mich hat das sehr gefreut bei der Eröffnung als Erdgeist und äh Gerardinen gefragt haben,
Wie viele Leute waren denn das erste Mal auf dem Kongress und ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, manche Leute sagen dreißig Prozent. Ich habe gesagt, es ging so ungefähr die Hälfte der Hände hoch. Würde das gern hier im Sendezentrum machen. Sind ja so hundert, hundertfünfzig Leute hier. Wer von euch ist denn das erste Mal auf dem Kongress?
Krass, oder?
Die Hälfte, ja. Ja, Ca.
Also kämpft mit wieder voll.
Mache mir da auch keine Illusionen. Ist ja auch gut so. Linus, du hattest auch noch was.
Ja, aber das mache ich ja immer erst ganz am Ende. Damit wäre ja dann die Sendung vorbei.
Ja, ist ja eigentlich auch schon fast vorbei.
Meine Biersäule.
Oh nee, okay, dann das geht jetzt natürlich unhaltbarer Zustand. Insofern danke ich an dieser Stelle Philipp, Lars, Hannes, Elke, Daniel und und Benedikt.
Und ich danke Sven.
Für ungenannte Dienstleistungen.
Denke, da geht ihr mir in meine Dankesrede rein.
Ja, einfach so.
Allen Zuhörern und sonstigen Unterstützern, vor allem hier im Sendezentrum.
Genau und das war's. Politik live, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank fürs Dabei bleiben, wir senden weiter im nächsten Jahr, wie ihr es kennt. Und das war's, tschüss.
Tschüss.